what's going on people thank you so much
for being here we're going to make this
super quick because our last one ended
with a gripping cliffhanger we're going
to watch squid game episode 5 today
called a fair world i am more than
enthused to be checking this out right
now please go ahead and hit that like
button if you end up enjoying our
reaction or the dislike doesn't matter
which one either way make sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell get notified reaction for the next
episode is up full length watch along is
over at our patreon page for squid game
where you sync up with the time code
cover a whole bunch of shows over there
we're at the same tier you get the
optimal reaction highlights and watch
that included the real last thing is
actually they get a piper prepper
prepper proper here's how it spells
thank you guys ready to have the
highlights for us let's freaking do this
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god my nipples just got so hard
oh my god oh my god
[Laughter]
go through with it come on just kill him
no time to have a conflict kill him
[Applause]
oh that's [ __ ] oh what
what
okay
hey you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wow what a shot
that's what an opening they really know
how to start a mood
oh i hate the details of how some of
them still live behind
hey
some of those falls get broken i love it
but i hate it at the same time yeah
that's right
that's right what's up
what's up
[Music]
oh
i thought they wrap it like a bow
yeah like a present hey or a box of
chocolates or something
oh my god lady you are the worst i hate
you so much
this is just a horrible microcosm for
planet earth
to school for business
graduates off
let's agree not to kill each other
[Laughter]
set the bar low
what's up
he's going to be taking a [ __ ] for like
six hours yeah
it happens around here
a lot
of
marijuana
[Music]
[Music]
oh man
what if his brother's on the staff yeah
what if his brother like
is pulling some strings here
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
what the hell is going on
the umbrella corporation will tell us
everything at the end
oh was that what was being triggered
when he was doing tug of war yeah
probably
someone else keeping watch right now
foreign
absolutely like i i always do every week
[Laughter]
this guy can't ask one question man i
know
he's good he's made it this far i gotta
give it to him
honking well
give me your luggage
[Music]
yeah
you're not invincible in here my guy
oh yeah
didn't you
anytime you ask me a question
such a
darkly lit episode huh yeah
this must have been fun to shoot
damn it dude
[Applause]
oh this is oh
[Music]
foreign
oh god
no this is so bad
oh
no
it's blood
[Music]
oh this door's in nowhere
this is a nightmare realm
the demented nightmare place
oh
knife to a gun fight
yeah i mean yeah it makes sense it's a
fascinating web of oppressions
[Music]
foreign
he's gonna do it you think i want to be
here he's gonna do it he'll take his
mask
don't kill him doc you're not going to
get out of this man don't kill okay
[Laughter]
wow where did he go from here came down
from the top first
oh
it okay so that's just like a total side
operated hustle
[Laughter]
foreign
[Laughter]
cousin
oh
oh now please don't be other people on
the other side
oh no
oh is that the main guy's lair his
office yeah got some nice fancy
furniture
oh hell yeah take this whole operation
pull this thing wide open
damn this dude is formidable yeah
oh
yeah
yeah
gotta get that bullet back
smart smart smart
dude isn't covering [ __ ] way too early i
i really hope he doesn't die
1999.
jesus
how's how far back does it go does do
winners sign like an nda or something
yeah
what
archives
oh my squid archives
oh
buddy
oh that's so sad
oh god
it's a tiny body
okay so there are actual winners
yeah do you go live on a special island
for winners
oh they don't even show space in the it
was really well framed yeah with the
flashlight yeah [ __ ] no blocking the
face out oh
man
oh boy okay let's chit chat stupid-ass
doctor yeah it's like you can't think
straight when you're sleep deprived
under a stressful secretive situation
you're financially broke life or death
constantly i've literally had to fight
for life
i've never seen your own life and death
probably flash in your mind's eye a few
times as well
stupid
that's all i got
no understanding i was that doctor i'd
be filling out kidneys left and right
sell these wherever you want they're all
perfect
damn sleep damn
that was uh that was a crazy ass episode
man yeah yeah i weirdly thought of the
movie enter the dragon did anyone else
infiltrating some secret game that's
happening here and then uh it's like the
way the structure is of kind of like
this uh tunnels almost catacomb-esque of
just the whole vibe the alarm started
going off i started to get the editor of
the dragon um this is where my mind went
but uh yeah that was that was a
different one holy crap it's it's
it's weird how like things are already
tense enough as it is being in the shoes
of the players
and the games they have to fulfill and
go through with and then you get this
other foreboding side of things where
things are going wrong with the [ __ ]
staff and
what's happening there and that's uh
that's intense like they just managed to
find like let's pull out some intensity
from this other side of the story now
here and it's like okay is this gonna
i don't want to spend forever predicting
how things are gonna go or trying to
but what i love is that it seems like
things are starting to
not necessarily collapse things haven't
fallen apart yet they really just got
like this one bug they gotta like kill
this one you know uh which is our our
cop here but then the mystery just keeps
ramping up like you begin to understand
what's really going on here as you
thought with the black market selling
body parts like that is what's being
fulfilled here but then
with his brother like oh [ __ ] i thought
he was like for sure dead or a member of
the staff and then finally he's the
winner but it's like what [ __ ]
happens with the winners
and that's such like so in line with the
kinds of revelations they've been lacing
through this so far is yeah what's the
the last thing you'd have thought and
the most like oh [ __ ] revelation oh he
won that's even crazier that is crazier
because now it's like well where did he
go where did he go where did he go and
if it's been going on for this for for
such a long time you know like
what's the history of the winners yeah
you know what where did who
they all they learned to keep out of
debt and they just live
affluent [ __ ] who forgot everything
about where they came from they become
one of the people betting on all these
guys find his brother in the last
episode he's gonna be like oh i'm so
sorry have some caviar
it's gonna be great
yeah man i'm really rooting for a cop
i'm not really rooting for him he's uh
he's i really care about him because
he's like the one right of light here is
one
one
one little sliver of hope
maybe just maybe we have a chance
oh but it's like no okay how can this
one guy bring this all down how can he
call john mclean on this whole situation
you know it's impossible i'm sorry for
him what the hell's gonna do you know
but i love what they've been able to do
with him in this episode especially
because they stretched i think kind of
the limits of okay you're following him
around with a bunch of other people with
circles on their faces too
and the way they were able still to put
you in his shoes and and put you into
the tension of each of those scenes that
he's at least directly involved in like
they kept again like they've had such a
great showcase of tension and flavors of
tension across the episodes we've seen
so far
and this just added another facet to
that like i really liked the very
intense sneaking sort of detective work
aspect this threw in and then yeah you
get this revelation i mean through an
episode that seems like it's taking this
theme of like trust and very specific
like traumatic events for people like
you know you you have a lot of displays
of before people learning each other's
names and now it's like okay these
behind the scenes the guards are like
negotiating
by showing their faces and creating
common ground and stuff like that and
they've yeah run such beautiful tension
out of that up to this point and
here it's like how much further can he
go it seems like now his back is really
truly against the wall because he has
that square mask somewhere but like i
don't know where he's gonna slip off to
yeah he'll find hopefully he finds a way
or i don't know maybe the the guy with
the mask the the main guy will take a
liking to them because what they've been
doing here is they've been doing this
like
it
as they go through the journey of the
game slowly it's like they peel off the
layers of who these people are
underneath you know and it's not it's
not it doesn't seem like it's going down
this i don't know maybe we've got a few
episodes left maybe it's going down the
direction of
of uh that's typical survival of the
fittest things that we're all savages
underneath the surface you know all it
takes is pushing us up against the right
wall under the right deprivations and
we'll do anything we have to
but it doesn't seem like it's going that
path if anything you see more of the
understanding of uh the backstory of
these people or or actually that there
is more good and sensitivity and
softness to these people than maybe once
thought like i really like the
the the night watch moment here whether
where they're shifting and then they're
bonding with each other getting to
understand like all these just like he's
the best man he's just such a
nice character nice guy man such a great
guy
and uh yeah and then the song and is
that he say it
song
i
think
like the bonding experience they're
having there's like we haven't really
touched on anything here
with our main character and his father
like we've seen a lot with the mom and
of course how he struggles with being a
dad himself
and there's been some like reflective
mirroring aspects visually at least with
perhaps he worries about winding up in
his position one day where he's an old
man having to be here
but it seems like there is that sense
you get from the main character here
that
um
like some longing for
fatherhood or something or some rep
reprimanding of some
being a bad father himself or there
there's there's little like qualities
here that i'm not exactly sure what it
is but it seems like so specific
in terms of father-son dynamic you know
yeah it seems like they are taking care
to lace in these
in some cases quite subtle or more in
the performance or more in little lines
of dialogue but yeah these these
character details and that was something
that came out i thought in these like
the quiet moment where he's keeping
watch and then he seems to be almost
having like a traumatic flashback to
that protest situation that he was in
and i thought that was kind of reflected
too in number one at the end you know i
thought he was almost going through some
kind of post traumatic like the sirens
are wailing and it almost was like this
guy's got to have been old enough to
remember you know some pretty nasty wars
in his lifetime like i wonder if
you know those things are at play
underneath all this and now being held
in this weird prison-like scenario where
you're you know being forced to do
things by guards who are smaller cogs
and bigger machines than
you know they realize blah blah like
well i like how with
our main character like
i think
i like how with watching him here who
started off so cowardly
were progressively it's so um
it's so subtle like it's just been
germinating throughout the series of
he's becoming
more assertive and sure of himself
in the decisions and what he has to go
through with even talking to the thug
guy you know like he doesn't cower away
he's just really straight he's kind of
straightforward with him
and you're seeing him grow and develop
like when he's interacting with pit
pocket lady
um
it was kind of like this ironic laugh
that he has about how she says you owe
me a message
actually like there was a wonderful
levity in that scene because you really
feel like this is a it has that laugh of
a familial kind of like yeah it's good
yeah you know and we've somehow in a
twisted way bonded through all these
crazy experiences you're watching you're
watching him grow up through these
experiences and become more of a man you
know yeah it's it's fascinating to see
because they're not
drawing a lot of attention to it they're
just letting the scenes go but it's he's
behaving very different than he did in
the
in the earlier episodes which was a lot
more you know cowardly and childish yeah
and here you're watching him become like
sort of like the other guy from the
university you know
he's he is uh excuse like you say the
name on the subtitle i i obviously know
who they're talking about yeah but i
don't know i can't receive this
yeah um it's okay i've got one or two
names come in i got holly
but yeah with uh with the guy from the
university it's like he's sort of
positioned as you you're looked at more
as like the captain but the guy we've
been following he's solely been becoming
like the leader of the team yeah i mean
he seems like he's just developing this
much more like you said assured and
steady presence where like yeah if he
has input people are probably gonna
listen and he kind of by now sort of
knows the game and knows enough to be
conscientious about what he's talking
about and it's a really natural growth
in his just demeanor like you said the
way he talks to the thug dude it just
comes across in how he carries himself
now as they go forward and i loved what
that led to as well because all it does
is drop the idea in about like look at
all these dudes you've amassed like do
you think any of them are trustworthy
for real and i love that it doesn't even
devolve by the end into them all killing
each other because there's other stuff
that's gonna happen but yeah it's just
enough for them to actually run some
like subtle little trust experiments and
watch as everybody's cogs turn in that
way well even when i like the little
touches you get with our main guy
as he like
he laments this whole speech
about
like no this game is beautiful and
you're ruining the whole point like
these people suffer and we're giving
them a chance it's something fair they
can't fight and know that if they fight
they play by the rules they can win all
right you guys are gonna get where
you're coming from you seem like you
really mean that yeah yeah
yeah i'm excited to do this for the
money
she said this is never about the money
sell organs do whatever you need to do i
am about the purity of the game it seems
it seems sincere and it mean
they craft a good villain they're a good
head honcho because of the fact that he
is uh he he doesn't seem to get
as provoked as he is and he makes these
tough decisions and he has ninja-like
abilities where no one can see all those
people sticking up on yeah
but
what he does what's cool is he he keeps
us cool you know like no matter what uh
no matter how intense the situations are
getting you see that a lot of these
soldiers are staffed they get a a rise
can come out of them they he he
specifically stays calm and collected in
the midst of an intense situation i do
like what you're talking about earlier i
think that's one this quality of this
that i really have grown to appreciate
is they managed to draw intent
specifically the word intensity and or
suspense comes to mind from
either the mystery of a situation or the
game
but then they manage it to find it just
through like
interaction like with the doctor when
he's trying to break out you know or or
or a cop as he
has a guy at gunpoint you know or
anytime he's asking a question i was
like a question
he looks at anything
yeah
everyone is just uh so on edge here and
incredibly suspicious of one another
it's
it's a really engaging show and it's
cool how like they they
keep they they always present new
questions but it doesn't feel
overwhelming yeah like they they really
are are good at spreading them out again
focus it seems really focused in the way
that they do that as they give you a
couple themes and a couple reveals and
they really let those play out and they
really let you see how they live out
from every angle like i like that they
take the time and and it made for a
really natural transition here where
it's like we're used to seeing them
wheel out their big pink ribbon boxes
and put people in the cremation cycle uh
except now we see you know like the
further reaches of that and through that
then we learn what position the grunts
are in which is interesting too because
you know it's like we don't know how and
why they're all here are they under
leverage under some kind of different
contract or do they volunteer
uh but either way it seems like even
them like that whole revelation even
though it's almost obvious you're like
wow it's more of a big deal if a player
gets killed than if yeah anyone on staff
gets killed that's gotta get unpacked
probably pretty soon well i think the
big deal was like oh these guys are
doing something they're not supposed to
be doing but then you find out like he
doesn't even give a [ __ ] that
the main guy what you want he doesn't
care all all he cares about is that you
ruined the whole point of the game
by feeding this guy yeah yeah yeah like
he didn't care about any other
discussion
on his own free time as long as you give
him nothing
yeah
this is fascinating it's fascinating
yeah all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below hit that
like button or dislike doesn't matter
which one
and uh we'll see you guys soon thanks
for being trick us on patreon
uh wait no we should do a page patron of
the day
look the one who could really survive
this squid game world it's gonna be
lance door yeah he's the only one on our
patreon page who has a law enforcement
record that's that's an injury he's a
firefighter he understands what it's
like to have to go through these types
of different obstacles when it comes he
could be the role of the doctor too if
he needs to be for checking up on people
with medical
necessities and needs you know after
playing a certain game i feel like he's
the perfect candidate for such a thing
you know even just the training courses
they make you go through as a
firefighter i'm like well yeah he could
easily do like a lot of these absolutely
he would lead a team he would probably
get promoted you know pulled back in and
made to be one of like the triangle or
square level uh you know soldier guys
because i mean lance he's strong think
about how many games you can help set up
too he'd probably skip a great they'd
probably be like wow you're so good
we're just hopping into the last level
we're getting you a new shape entirely
for your man
we're gonna put a rhombus on yours i
feel like special lance would be perfect
for this i think so and you know with
you having a kid now and you know
getting married it's financially
difficult so let's play some games too
put your kid in the game then it could
be they could be occupied while you work
that's that's that's where this improv
went yep yeah
this would get darker kind of got a lot
further than i went it was going to go
okay just toss through the ball
running in for a touchdown
this is always a hail mirror
[Music]